one of the stories last year that joe
montana was commenting on was this
notion of tom brady
leaving new england joe montana said he
shouldn't
tom brady did and it's worked out pretty
well so far for tom brady so
this year the quarterback carousel is
going to be
a lot more robust it's not just brady
there's a bunch of guys and as we bring
in miles simmons we say good afternoon
to him and miles i want to start with
you
you haven't chimed in yet on desean
watson shereen and i spent a lot of time
talking about it what's your gut
reaction
when you hear watson wants out
and of course the texans are initially
going to say
we want to keep him how do you think
this is going to play out
i think first of all it's fascinating
because it it sort of speaks to the
level of player empowerment that we're
seeing in the nba that we just haven't
really
seen so far in the nfl and i kind of
love it
just from a chaos standpoint because
it's just not really something we've
seen before and i don't know i kind of
love the chaos a little bit especially
when nobody gets hurt
so this is something where i i kind of
think it makes a lot of sense
for deshaun watson to want to go to
miami because
a that team won 10 games last year it's
clearly on the rise
and they've got if you're miami you've
got some questions surrounding tua
tagovailoa and how he can
actually do better um because look you
used ryan fitzpatrick as a relief
pitcher so
that makes sense to me and from the
standpoint that florida doesn't have
any state income tax so he's already
used to that with texas
and if he wants to go to new jersey say
and play for the jets then
that's an entirely different tax
situation too so i mean if i'm a player
i want to maximize the chance for me to
win and i want to maximize the chance
for me to make as much money as possible
and i think miami would kind of make
sense for him in that way
miles i i hope he goes to miami just
simply because i think they're ready to
win now and lacking the quarterback if i
had to bet on a team i'm going to bet on
the jets for two reasons we know that he
wanted the texans to interview robert
sala
so we think that sean watson wants to go
play with for
robert sala and i think he wants to go
play
in the new york market because speaking
of that money there is a state income
tax but he thinks he can make more money
in the new york market now i would argue
that patrick mahomes
and aaron rodgers have done fantastic
things marketing wise outside of
football
and they play in small market cities so
and it's not like houston is a small
market city frankly so he can do all
those things elsewhere i don't think it
necessarily has to be in that big market
but if i'm going to bet on a team mike
i'm going to bet on the jets for deshaun
watson because of all the picks they
have and what they can give up to get
him
and if you're the jets it's so easy to
justify
giving up whatever it takes to get the
thing you haven't had since joe namath
a true franchise quarterback and to sell
all the tickets and the psl's and
everything that they have struggled to
maximize
since they opened metlife stadium a
decade ago that's what the jets need
and they have two first-round picks that
they got for a guy
who didn't want to be there and they had
gotten to the point where they didn't
want him there anymore and jamal adams
throw those two picks onto the pile and
if you have to throw in the second
overall pick this year
to get it done do it and you get to sean
watson to me
it's a no-brainer all right shireen we
talked earlier about the possibility of
matthew stafford going to houston
i want and i'm going to sorry control
room in advance i'm going to combine the
next two into one
what if the cowboys decide
instead of continuing to be
in this franchise tag dance with dak
prescott 37.4 million
this year 53 million next year if they
tag
him again and i'd be stunned if they
devote that much because it's a 44
raise by rule for the third franchise
tag what if the cowboys say
and and look mike mccarthy competed
against matthew stafford he may secretly
think he's awesome
what if they just say we can spend a
hell of a lot less money on a guy who's
only 32 who can come in here and run
this offense and throw the ball all over
the place
and that's what we're going to do do you
think there's any way that the cowboys
entertain that possibility and oh by the
way he's from dallas and
played here for forever so everybody
knows him here i don't see any possible
way that happens mike if i'm going to
bet on it i'm going to bet on matthew
stafford
to go to the colts i think he fits their
offense and
and what they're going to do what they
want to do if they can't get carson
wentz who we know
frank reich's history with carson wentz
then i think matthew stafford is a
really good alternative
now i would make a phone call from the
colts to
i started to say oliver luck but andrew
luck who retired obviously and would
cost them nothing to get
but the colts have shown they're willing
to trade draft picks for good players
they did it last year with deforest
buckner and that worked out
great for him i think the cowboys are
going to get
dak press got signed to a long-term deal
i don't think they have a choice
jerry wants to keep dak prescott and
he's never lost a player who he's really
one
wanted to keep ever and so i think he
gets
that cra he's going to pay more than he
wants to pay but i think they get dak
press got signed to a long-term deal
i think they have to get him signed to a
long-term deal right
it's just the only thing that seems to
make logical sense for me
because if you look at it and you know
you have to hope
that uh dak prescott can be the kind of
quarterback that he was before he
suffered that injury last year but
i think dak prescott has always been a
better quarterback than matthew stafford
so
if you're talking about dak prescott and
maybe going away from him then
it's got to be because he's really not
healthy and you
know that he's not healthy and i think
that would be the only way that matthew
stafford could be an upgrade despite you
know the cost and money and all those
different types of things
but i also think that if you're talking
about matthew stafford he's somebody
that
probably will land with the colts the
cults seem to make the most sense
because they are out of the conference
they do have a reputation for spending
the draft capital
that they need to but if you're
washington i think you got to make that
call as well because you've got a team
that has a darn good defense
you've got some pieces on offense too
and so if you have that quarterback
that's not just tyler heinecke
you know maybe that thing gets that
thing tips a little bit
and you can really do some good things
and make it to the playoffs and be a
real contender in the nfc east but
you know one team that i think maybe
should make that call to the lions too
is the rams because now you've got all
these connections
between these front offices and i know
that the jared goff contract is hard to
get out from under unless knee talked
about how there are ways that they can
do that yesterday
but if you're the rams and you get a
quarterback like that
if you pair him with that defense that's
good and if you somehow can make that
work with the picks and the money and
all that i think that would be really
interesting a really good move
and i agree that the cowboys very much
want to keep dak prescott and get him
signed to a long-term contract the
dynamic here that we can't overlook
dak has never wavered on the leverage
that he has accumulated
and this year he's got a lot more than
last year
because he can look at it and he can say
i get 37.4
for one more year and next year unless
you want to pay me
53 4. and chances are maybe they would
instead use a transition tag
at a 20 bump but that's still 44 45
million
i think he'll still be inclined even
coming off of that broken ankle
to go year to year to keep betting on
himself until the cowboys give him
something that he thinks properly
reflects his long-term value
to the team and that only is a four-year
commitment instead of a five-year
commitment on which the cowboys have
been insisting
all right in the nfc north the
packers the champions of that division
again 13-3 again they clearly want aaron
rodgers back
i believe aaron rodgers wants clarity
about his future
is it a one-year thing is it a two-year
thing is it a three-year thing how does
jordan love figure into this
miles we haven't had a chance to talk to
you about this on the show this week
obviously
it's been a big point of conversation
what are your thoughts about
where aaron rodgers will be and will he
get the kind of commitment
that lets him know in green bay it's not
just a year-to-year arrangement
if the packers are smart that's what
they should do i mean because as you
pointed out mike
plenty of times look aaron rodgers is
getting paid the same amount of money
that jared goff is
and that is just not right i mean i i
think that we can say that just based on
the performance of both of those guys
if that's what the case is something's a
little bit wrong there
so when the packers decided to draft
jordan love
i mean we all know that they may or may
not have you know put a little extra
motivation in the cup of aaron rodgers
but if rogers goes out there and he does
what he's done
this year and now he's the likely mvp
yeah he deserves to have that kind of
commitment
from the packers to say look we're not
going to get rid of you anytime soon and
i think that's something that tom brady
wanted
when they drafted jimmy garoppolo and
things worked out well enough
for the patriots that they went on to
win another super bowl so
look i think that if you are the packers
right now and
mark murphy say this it would be stupid
to not necessarily give aaron rodgers
the type of commitment that he
wants so that you can not only just
reach the nfc championship game next
year
but maybe you're playing in the super
bowl and you're finally getting
i guess maximizing what aaron rodgers
potential is because he's only played in
one super bowl which is just
kind of weird to me but i mean just it's
the way his careers worked out
miles if he wasn't coming off an mvp
season
and we'll get shireen back look let me
pick up where shireen was going
if he isn't coming off of an mvp season
then the packers may be thinking do we
go to jordan love not necessarily 2021
but how much do we accelerate his
progress so we could go to him in 2022
and
you know i resolved this whole thing in
my mind very simply
aaron rodgers wants to know is jordan
love
jimmy garoppolo who's going to get
traded in a few years and i'm still the
guy
or is jordan love me the guy who was
behind brett favre
who eventually got installed as the
starting quarterback miles and i think
that's
the core of this he wants to know
where he stands and then once he knows
where he stands
he can make his decisions accordingly
yeah and i think
like you said mike he deserves that and
if it was a season where he didn't play
as well as he played then i think all of
us would probably be
questioning whether or not the packers
need to turn to jordan love
because you don't pick that guy in that
round
trading up to get him without the
intention of actually playing him
at some point over the course of his
career i
i just don't think that that's what you
do if they really were doing that then
maybe they would have selected a
quarterback later on
and then they would have given aaron
rodgers another weapon
for the offense or maybe pick somebody
for the defense that could have been a
contributor right away
they didn't really get any of that done
with last year's draft class
for the packers so now i think that
aaron rodgers is in a place where
if he really wants to get out of green
bay we know that he can't he could be
another one of these guys that starts
the whole player empowerment thing right
where he says you know what i don't
really think i want to play here anymore
if this is the way you guys are going to
treat me i'm not happy with this
you need to send me somewhere else and
if that would be the case
then that would be massive because even
though deshawn watson
is younger and probably would command
more in a trade and will command more in
a trade
aaron rodgers is still proven that he
is one of the best quarterbacks in the
game again we're talking about him being
the mvp this year so
that would be very fascinating i just
feel like at this point
you're right mike he wants that
commitment from the pan from the packers
i should say
and if they're smart they're gonna give
it to him
yeah i agree completely and uh we'll
find out
sooner rather than later i think what
they're thinking and whether or not
there's gonna be a new contract for
aaron rodgers that would give him
that clarity and in turn the commitment
that he is looking for and also
you know he wants some of these other
guys to be kept around it's going to be
tough this year with the salary cap
shrinking
but also there may be opportunities to
go out and buy some free agents who get
cut by other teams
and are saying hey we'll sign on for the
green bay packers we want to try to win
a super bowl during this year where the
salary cap is going to constrict
all right ben roethlisberger news today
and he was a guy that i put in the
uncertain category
because we needed to hear more about his
contract
art rooney ii the owner of the team said
today we'd like to see ben back for
another year
if that can work but there's a lot of
work to do to see if that can happen
we've been up front with ben and letting
him know
we couldn't have him back under the
current contract he understands we have
to do
some work there now first of all we'd
like to have him back for another year
that implies one more year
and secondly and this is a point that
we've addressed at pft
rothersburg's cap number this year is
over 41 million it's 41.25 million
they need to extend the contract take
the money he's due to make this year
turn as much of it as they can into a
guarantee and push that
cap number into future years and you can
shrink it into the range of it's going
to at least be 22
250 you can get it to 26
27 25 if you're really aggressive all
those dollars are going to hit the cap
at some point in the future miles
but that's the way to do it he still
gets every penny he's due to make this
year
but you do it in a way that you defer
that cap charge
to next year and possibly the year after
that and roethlisberger today said i
want to do everything i can
and made that clear to them from the
very beginning i don't care about my pay
at all this year i don't think that
means it's going to take less
but i think he's willing to do whatever
he needs to do contractually
to help them reduce the cap number so
they can have other players around him
yeah especially in a year where the cap
is going down like this i mean
he's got to be realistic in saying okay
i need to do something
so that the team can be good and can
compete
and get past the first round of the
playoffs even though they started 11-0
this year
this is something that's interesting
though because mike i don't know
how you felt about it but when i saw ben
roethlisberger in tears
on the sideline at the end of that game
in the divisional round against the
browns
i kind of thought that he was the guy
that looked like this was the end for
him and so
i didn't necessarily know exactly what
that would look like where
ben roethlisberger might retire but he's
a guy who's been
beat up who's been battered he's had
elbow issues he's come back and he
played you know at a pretty high level
this year
but i just wasn't sure that he was
somebody that really wanted to come back
for another year of this
and so it was a little bit surprising to
me to hear to see his quotes today
and see that yeah he was willing to do
whatever it takes to come back and
the notion that he probably doesn't care
about is salary i mean everybody cares
about
how much money they're gonna make i know
that that's a nice thing to say but i
don't believe that it's true
but i am sort of surprised that he does
want to come back instead of retiring
thank you thank you i could hear you
guys i just couldn't apparently you
couldn't hear me
but i i'm with you myles i i think i i
saw when i saw
ben roethlisberger sitting on the bench
i thought that's it for him but
i do think he's back in pittsburgh mike
for one more year at least
uh and kind of see how that plays out
but if i'm the steelers i'm
certainly thinking about finding a
franchise quarterback
i can groom to come in behind him
whether that's a draft or some young guy
somewhere else because they need to
start thinking about the future
the the other side of this though how
much cap room are they going to have to
put a team around ben that's going to
help ben get to where he wants to be
and does he really want to come back if
it's going to be another year where it
all kind of fizzles apart down
the end of the stretch is that really
worth it to him if they don't think
and if he doesn't think they're going to
have a team that's going to compete with
the likes of
the ravens and the chiefs and the bills
and these other great teams in the afc
you get to a certain point where like
i don't know that i want to do this and
you know it may be
and this may be a topic to really delve
into more
on a later date but i i can't help but
wonder whether or not
there's a certain amount of no one wants
to be the bad guy
here the steelers don't want to say we
don't want him
ben doesn't want to say i want to retire
because the steelers could say you owe
us twelve and a half million dollars
in unearned signing bonus money if they
really wanted to do that
i just i'm not sold that they're going
to work this out
because i don't know how much cap space
they're really going to save
and if it does drop to 180 i don't know
how you put a team around him and if
marquis pouncey retires
what do you do there and it was always
this sense those two were joined at the
hip so
i i don't think it's over yet i'm still
going to keep an eye on it
and i still think there's a chance he
retires and i think if he knew he didn't
know that money
that 12 and a half million maybe he
would say i think it's just time
at this point to move on hi i'm mike
tarico and thanks for watching
make sure to hit subscribe for the
latest news and highlights
from nbc sports